[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها كالمعتاد بالعناوين
من تؤاد صيني يجدد التوتر استدعاء القائمه
باعمال الصين في واشنطن تدعو بالتهدئه
الامراض الوراثيه تؤرق الاسر معدلاتها
مرتفعه في السعوديه وزواج الاقارب السبب
الاكبر
اول حافله كهربائيه لنقل الركاب في جده
شحنه واحده تكفي لقطع 300 كيلو متر
في الرابعه ايضا
استمرار اعمال التطوير في قلعه زعبل في
شمال السعوديه شاهد تاريخي يمتد لاربعه
قرون
ازمه تجدد التوتر بين الصين والولايات
المتحده هذه المره عبر منطاد تجسس صيني في
سماء الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
صاحبها الكثير من ردود الافعال من الطرفين
احدثها ما نقلته صحيفه
الامريكيه القائمه بالاعمال الصيني
جورنال كشفت ايضا ان لجنتي الاستخبارات في
الكونغرس يطالبان بالرد على منطاد التجسس
الصيني ومن جهتها نقلت صحيفه بلومبرج عن
رئيس الامريكي بايدن انه رفض نصيحه
البنتاجون باسقاط منطاد التجسس الصيني
خوفا من سقوط حطامه على المدن
اجواء مشحونه بين واشنطن وبيكين في الارض
والسماء تسبق زياره مرتقبه لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الى بكين من تادون صيني يحوم في
سماء امريكا لاهداف تجسسيه وتعقب متواصل
لمسار حركه المنطاد من قبل البنتاجون لكن
اسقاطه لم يعد امرا واردا نظرا لما قد
يشكله من اضرار على مناطق سكنيه وفق ما
ذكر مسؤول دفاعي امريكي كبير تصريحات
مسؤول الدفاع الامريكيه اوضحت مسار ووجهه
المنطاد الصينيه فقبل عده ايام اخترق
المنطاد الصيني المجال الجوي الامريكي
ونحو قواعد جويه ومخازن صواريخ استراتيجيه
في ولايه مونتانا شمال غربيه امريكا يحلق
المنطاد عاليا على ارتفاع اعلى بكثير من
الحركه الجويه التجاريه وعاقب مشاورات
عسكريه امريكيه اقترب الطائرات مقاتله من
المنطاد فوق مونتانا دون ان تتخذ قرارا
باسقاته وفقا لوكاله الانباء الفرنسيه فان
واشنطن ابلغت بكين بخطوره الواقعه موضحه
انها ستفعل كل ما هو ضروري لحمايه شعبها
على اراضيها تحذير واجهته الصين بدعوه لحل
المساله بهدوء وحذر
وتؤدى
انتهاك اراضي اي دوله او مجالها الجوي يجب
حل المساله بهدوء وحذر ولا معلومات عن
زياره مرتقبه لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي الى
الصين اما مجلس النواب الامريكي فطلب
الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه بعدم الصمت ما
تقوم به الصين عمل مزعزع للاستقرار
ويتجاهل سياده الولايات المتحده بدون خجل
ادعو الرئيس بايدن الى عدم التزام الصمت
وابلاغ اعضاء الكونجرس بالمستجدات
من جهته طلب الرئيس بايدن من وزير الدفاعه
بحث الخيارات المتاحه مع قيادات الجيش في
البنتاغون ووفقا لبيان وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه فان المنطاد لا يشكل تهديدا
عسكريا او جسديا لمن هم على الارض وعلى
الرغم من القيمه المحدوده للمنطاد
استخباراتيا وفق مسؤولين الا انه قد يزيد
من حده التوترات الصينيه الامريكيه
العسكريه والسياسيه في شرق اسيا علي
السمان العربيه
من امام الكاب ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
حسين التوت حسين مرحبا بك حسين اريد
ان اسالك وين الامر يعني فيه الكثير من
الغرابه من طرد بحجم ثلاثه باصات تقريبا
كما تقول الروايه الامريكيه
يقطع مسافه اكثر من
2480 ميل من الاسكا في شمال الى مونتانا
لا يكتشفه سوى مواطن عادي يرصده بكاميرا
موبايل وبشكل كذلك يدعو الى الى الى
السخريه كيف كيف يمكن النظر الى هذه
الروايه يعني وهذا هذه الامر او المنطاد
المفاجئ في سماء الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
صباح الخير خالد بالفعل كل شيء غريب حول
هذا المنطاد وحتى اذا عرفنا ان الصين
لديها اقمار صناعيه اصلا تحلق فوق
الولايات المتحده في الفضاء الخارجي
ولديها القدره على التجسس وعلى التقاط
الصور عاليه الدقه وهذا ايضا يطرح تساؤلات
عده لماذا ترسل هذا المنطاد ليحلق في علوم
مرتفع هو فوق العنوان الذي تحلق فيه
طائرات المدنيه والتجاريه ولكن ايضا هذا
سؤال مطروح بقوه ما حاجتها لهذا المنطاد
طبعا كل ما تفضلت به هناك الان معلومه
جديده قراته قبل لي قبل قليل بان من اكتشف
هذا المنطاد هم ركاب على طائره تجاريه
اصلا كانوا يمرون فوق مونتانا هذا هذه
المعلومات كلها ادت الى توجيه انتقادات
عده اصلا من قبل مسؤولين هنا ونسيمه في
الكونجرس الامريكي وخاصه من الجمهوريين
كبير الجمهوريين في لجنه القوات المسلحه
في مجلس الشيوخ روجرز انتقد وزاره الدفاع
وقال انها لم تتعامل مع قضيه المنطاد بشكل
طارئ وقال انه لا يجب السماح بحدوث هكذا
اختراق للاجواء الامريكيه ايضا اليوم
السيناتور تنقاطا ووسي جمهوري بارز في
مجلس الشيوخ طالب باسقاط هذا المنطاد
واكتشاف ما هي المعلومات التي تم الحصول
عليها من قبل الصينيين الامور تتفاعل وكما
تفضلت في الخبر في رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي ايضا طلب بتقديم معلومات الى
قاده الكونغرس هناك ايضا دعوات للرئيس
بايدن لا يتوقف عن السياسه التي يصفونها
بالسياسه لينه وسياسه استرضاء الصين
واتخاذ قرارات حازمه خاصه قبيل الزياره
المرتقبه لوزير الخارجيه الى الصين
الاسبوع المقبل اذا هناك تفاعلات الان في
في الولايات المتحده بشان هذا الاختراق
اذا كان بالفعل هو من طابق صيني حتى الان
هناك ممكن ترجيحات بانه منطاد صيني ولكن
يضع علامات استفهام كثيره نعم هل يمكن ان
تمرر يعني هذه المساله مساله اختراق يعني
لمنطقه بهذا الحجم يقطع كل هذه المسافه في
وجود اجهزه واقمار اصطناعيه هي الاولى على
مستوى العالم خاصه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ثم روايه الرئيس الامريكي بانه
رفض نصيحه البنت البنتاجون باسقاط المنطاد
خوفا من سقوط حطامه على المدن الا يرصد
اولا كل هذه المسافه ثم ان لا يسقط خوفا
على على سقوطها على من سقوطه على ضحايا هل
كل هذه المنطقه 2400 ميلي هي كلها مناطق
ماهوله بالسكان حتى يعني يصعب اسقاطها
عاده في المناطق الشماليه في الولايات
المتحده وخاصه هناك الكثير من الغابات
ولكن لربما هو في منطقه بالفعل فوق مدينه
معينه عندها سيصعب اسقطه لان حطاما قد
يتناثر وقد يسقط على مساحات شاسعه يتواجد
فيها مواطنون ولكن اذا ربما اذا طار
لمسافه ابعد واصبح فوق منطقه يمكن
اعتبارها منطقه نائيه اي عدد السكان فيها
اقل ربما يتعاملون معها بطريقه مختلفه
ولكن ايضا نتحدث تقنيا يمكن لربما يمكن
احداث اختراق معين ما يؤدي الى هبوط هذا
المنطاد بشكل تدريجي ولكن حتى الان يبدو
ان الامريكيين اما لا يعرفون طبيعه الماده
المركبه او المصنعه لهذا المنطاد ربما اذا
تم استهدافها برصاصه او استهدافها باي شيء
ربما تنفجر في الفضاء او في الغلاف عفوا
في الاجواء الامريكيه مياده الى تماثلها
الا اذا كان من نوع مطاطي مثلا او من نوع
هناك
مستخدمه في صناع ربما او تكون به مواهب
بشكل تدريجي هذا هذه كل هذه الامور يجب
هذه كلها الامور يجب ان تدرس قبل عفوا
البعض ذهب الى ان تقوم
لذلك يجب ان يكونوا حذرين كما قال الرئيس
الامريكي هذه كيف ستؤثر على زياره الرئيس
اوزيل الخارجيه
يعني هل كان من ضمن العمليه عدم مثلا الان
بدانا نسمع الكثير من الانتقادات
سامحني على تاخر الصوت حسين نريد بس فقط
هل ستؤثر على مساله زياره وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الى الى بكين وهي الزياره الاولى
لوزير خارجيه امريكي منذ ست سنوات تقريبا
حتى الان الزياره قائمه لم يعلن عن
الغائها او اي شيء من هذا القبيل ولكن من
المؤكد ان هذا الموضوع سيكون على اولويات
الملفات التي سيناقشها الوزير انتوني
بلينكن مع المسؤولين الصينيين خلال
زيارتها الاسبوع المقبل هنا ونسيمه في ظل
الدعوات الان الى طرح هذا الموضوع بقوه
ولا الى توقف عن سياسه الاسترضاء كما
يصفها الجمهوريون للرئيس بايدن تجاه الصين
هذا الموضوع بالفعل موضوع يؤثر على
الملفات التي ستناقش طبعا الا اذا حدثت
هناك الان تطورات اخرى من هنا الى اسبوع
لا نعرف كيف ستكون الامور ولكن حتى الان
الزياره قائمه ومن المتوقع بقوه ان يكون
موضوع المنطاد هو من ابرز الملفات التي
سيتم مناقشتها طبعا ليست كمنطاد بل
الاختراقات الصينيه وبالمناسبه حسب ما
قرانا هذا ليست اول مره الصين ترسل
تتهم بارسال
الى الاجواء الامريكيه هناك معلومات عن
انها ارسلت قبل ذلك عدد منها هذا لكن هذا
المنطاد اخذ ضجه بسبب اكتشافه الان بواسطه
مواطنين مدنيين وايضا كما ذكرت احدى الصحف
الامريكيه بان احد الركاب في على طائره
تجاريه صور المنطاد في اجواء مونتانا هذا
الموضوع موضوع
التجسس الصيني الامريكي هو موضوع قديم ليس
جديدا يعني والكثير من التقارير الامريكيه
كتبت وكذلك الغربيه عن تجسس صيني في
الولايات المتحده وفي دول اوروبيه كثيره
يعني ولكن تجسس كان بوسائل هادئه ربما
توغل في مناطق معينه عبر الشخصيات معينه
تكشف او لا تكشف في اجهزه معينه كذلك لكن
ان يتم الحديث اليوم عن تجسس بطريقه
مفضوحه يعني
مختلفه تماما من هنا كيف سيؤثر على على
على على هذه المساله تحديدا يعني في ضوء
المطالبات
الموقف ربما اكثر صراما وتشددا الان مع
هذا الملف بين البلدين
خالد لا ننسى ايضا ان هناك اتهامات وجهت
لشركه تيك توك هناك دعوات لحضر هذا هذه
الابليكيشن هنا في الولايات المتحده
بالنسبه لموظفين الموظفين الفيدراليين
الصين حاولت اكثر من مره وفقا الامريكيين
التجسس عبر عده وسائل كانت تقنيه والان
هذا كما يقال انه منطاد صيني طبعا سيكون
هناك سياسات اكثر تشددا حتى في داخل
الكونغرس الامريكي متاكد بانه سيطرح قريبا
عدد من المشاريع
سيتبناها عدد من الاعضاء
الجمهوريه والديمقراطيين
لمواجهه هذه الموجه الصينيه من التجسس ومن
محاوله اختراق الولايات المتحده نذكر هناك
مشاريع الان تقدم بها السيناتور تم قاطا
اضافه الى السيناتور مارك روبيو وهو كبير
الجمهوريين في لجنه الاستخبارات الامريكيه
وهناك عدد اخر من الاعضاء يؤيدونهما بهذه
الاجراءات من المؤكد انه بعد هذه الحاله
بعد هذا الاختراق بواسطه البالون بالفعل
اذا كان منتظم صينيا سيكون هناك عدد من
المشاريع سنرى تحركات داخل مجلس النواب
ومجلس الشيوخ الامريكي لتشريع عدد من
القوانين لمواجهه الهيمنه الصينيه او عفوا
التدخل الصيني او النفوذ الصيني المتزايد
والتي تحاول من خلاله الصين
التجسس على الولايات المتحده على ان كنا
نتحدث عن الوكالات الفيدراليه او على
اشخاص معينين والان هناك هذه الطريقه
الجديده ربما بمحاوله اختراق الاجواء
الامريكيه والتي لا يستسيغها الامريكيون
ويرفضونها ان كنا نتحدث عن وزاره الدفاع
او عن مجلس الشيوخ ومجلس النواب كما ذكرت
هناك الان دعوات للتعامل بصرامه مع هذا
الموضوع هناك انتقادات وجهت لوزاره الدفاع
لكي لم تكتشفه واكتشف من قبل مواطنين
ودعوات لاسق في اسرع وقت ممكن ولمعرفه
ماذا تحتويه او ماذا يحتوي هذا المنطاد
شكرا جزيلا لك حسين العربيه من امام
الكابت في واشنط
ن هذا وصف الكاتب الصحفي الصيني نادر
رانجلتهامات الامريكيه المتعلقه بمنطاد
التجسس الصيني بانها غير منطقيه لان من
غير الممكن ان تستعين الصين بهذه الوسيله
البدائيه لممارسه التجسس على حد قوله تجسس
بوسيله المطاط هي وسيله بدائيه جدا
وكذلك
اذا كان هناك التجسس فلماذا لم تقم
باسقاطها الولايات المتحده
ورده
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا وبالتزامن
مع قمه اوكرانيه اوروبيه سمعت صافرات
الانذار في العاصمه كييف واعلن شارل ميشيل
رئيس المجلس الاوروبي عبر حسابه على تويتر
عن تواجده في كييف لحضور قمه الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع كل من الرئيس الاوكراني
زيلينسكي ورئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ارسنال لاين وممثل الشؤون الخارجيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي
وكان ميشيل في تغريدته على عدم التهاون
فيما يخص الازمه في اوكرانيا معبرا عن
التضامن مع اوكرانيا في رحلتها للانضمام
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
قمه روبيه اوكرانيه فيك القمه هي الرابعه
والعشرون بين الطرفين وهي الاولى من نوعها
منذ حصول اوكرانيا على صفه الدوله المرشحه
لعضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي حذيفه عادل من
داخل قاعه انعقاد المؤتمر
العالميه والعربيه والحدث في داخل قاعه
المؤتمرات حيث المؤتمر الصحفي للقمه
الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف نحن هنا حيث سينعقد هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي للرئيس زيليسكي ورئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه اورسولا فون لاين
وكذلك رئيس المجلس الاوروبي تشارل ميشيل
هذه المفاوضات استمرت في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه لمده يومين التقى فيها كبار
المفوضين والمسؤولين في المفوضيه
الاوروبيه بالمسؤولين وبالحكومه
الاوكرانيه اجريت عمليه مفاوضات شارك فيها
الرئيس فلاديمير زيلينسكي وحكومته وكذلك
اجريت بعض الاجتماعات بين بعض المسؤولين
ومسؤولين حكوميين اوكرانيين هنالك قضايا
رئيسيه واساسيه في اتجاه التكامل الاوروبي
للدوله الاوكرانيه التي تسعى طبعا
للاندماج في الاتحاد الاوروبي والدخول الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي قضيه القضاء واستقلاليه
القضاء والاصلاح في القضاء الاوكراني هذه
هذه احدى اهم القضايا هنا حيث اقف وفي هذه
المنصه سوف يكون بعد قليل المؤتمر الصحفي
للرئيس الاوكراني ورئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه
وكذلك رئيس المجلس الاوروبي ميشيل حيث
سيتم الاعلان عن نتائج هذه المفاوضات
الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه لقناتها العربيه
والحدث حذيفه عادل
وقبل ذلك طلب الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
بمنح فرصه حقيقيه لبلاده للانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي وقال انه يعتقد ان
اوكرانيا تستحق هذا العام الوصول الى
بدايه المفاوضات بشان عضويه الاتحاد
الاوروبي مؤكدا ان خطوه الاندماج مع
الاتحاد ستمنح الاوكرانيين الطاقه والحافز
للقتال على الرغم من اي عقبات وتهديدات
على حد وصفه
وافقت الحكومه الالمانيه على تسليم
اوكرانيا الدبابات اليوبد واحد في وقت اكد
فيه رئيس الوزراء النرويجي يونس جاستور في
مؤتمر صحفي عزم سلطات بلاده على شراء على
شراء اربعين دبابه من طراز من شركه
المانيا كما اعلنت توصل الى اتفاق لشراء
ثماني عشره وحده اخرى من المعدات
في الرابعه بعد الفاصل صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه
وارفارمرز الامريكيه اي واقعان اتفاقيه
لانشاء مزارع عموديه داخل السعوديه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد احصائيات مقلقه حول
مصابين الامراض الوراثيه للمواليد في
السعوديه كشف عنها البرنامج الوطني لفحص
الامراض الوراثيه عند المواليد في احدى
الحملات التوعويه الخاصه بالبرنامج وشارت
الاحصائيه الى ان السعوديه هي من اعلى
الدول في معدلات الاصابه بالامراض
الوراثيه السبب الاكبر زواج الاقارب
قرار خاطئ قد يجعل حياه الالاف من الاطفال
ناقصه ومليئه بالمعاناه نتيجه مرض وراثي
في السعوديه فقط تسجل اصابه واحده
بالامراض الوراثيه لكل الف مولود بمعدل
يقترب من خمسه اضعاف المعدلات العالميه
معروف ان الامراض الوراثيه المتنحيه نتيجه
زواج الاقارب تكون اكثر اذا كان اذا كان
هذا الشيء اللي هو منتشر فنسبه الامراض
الوراثيه عندنا متنحيه اكثر من دول الغرب
بالعكس حتلاقي دول الغرب عندهم الامراض
المتعلقه بالكروموسومات او الامراض
السائده اكثر من المتنحيه لانه ما عندهم
زواج اقارب فنحن نعتبر من الدول التي
تنتشر فيها بكثره اللي هو الامراض
الوراثيه المتنحيه زواج الاقارب يعد سبب
الاول لارتفاع معدلات الاصابه بالامراض
الوراثيه في السعوديه ما دفع وزاره الصحه
الى تنفيذ خطه كبرى لتخصيص استشاري لكل
اسره سعوديه ضمن التجمعات الصحيه في المدن
بهدف تعزيز الوقايه الصحيه والكشف مبكرا
عن الامراض ومعالجتها احنا برنامج طبيب
لكل اسره هو برنامج يهدف لمتابعه المريض
بشكل دوري تقريبا احنا عندنا كل اسبوع
لقاء مع فريق مكون من ممرض منسق حاله
ومدرب صحي يتناقشون في حالات المرضى او
يتم التواصل معهم الهاتفيا لمتابعتهم طبعا
لمتابعه تكون عن طريق وضع خطه علاجيه اما
كان علاجيا او وقائيا
ما قبل الزواج في السعوديه لا يكشف الا عن
مرضين وراثيين من بين الاف الامراض ولم
يحقق نتيجه في الحد من الامراض الوراثيه
على الرغم من التوصيات المستمره بزياده
انواع الامراض الوراثيه التي يشملها فحص
الزواج الالزامي من الرياض نواف عزيز
العربيه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا المشرف على
البرنامج الوطني لفحص الامراض الوراثيه
عند الموارد الاستشاريه الوراثه الطبيه
الدكتور ضياء عرفه دكتور ضياء حياك الله
معي في نشره الرابعه قبل عشرين سنه تقريبا
اقرت المملكه برنامج الفحص الصحي قبل
الزواج او ما سمي ببرنامج الزواج الصحي
المرحله الاولى كان عن الامراض الوراثيه
الدم ثم بعد ذلك الى الامراض الاخرى
منذ ذلك اليوم وحتى اليوم يعني بعد 20 سنه
اذا ما تحدثنا عن الارقام
هل هناك زياده في اعداد المصابين بهذه
الامراض الوراثيه
من الاقارب الذين يتزوجون بالرغم من من
ايجابيه الفحوصات التي تتم في هذا
البرنامج
اولا اشكركم على الدعوه واشكر العربيه على
جهودها في نشر التوعيه بالامراض الوراثيه
بالنسبه
للفحص الزواج هو يعتني بامراض الالتهابات
الكبده الفيروس وايضا الامراض الايمن
منجليه والبحر المتوسط اللي هي منتشره
عندنا بشكل كبير برضو في المنطقه
الى حد ما
وربما يعني يمكن حالات الامراض المتعلقه
بالدم قلت ان اول نعم قلت انا اول بكثير
لكن هناك امراض وراثيه اخرى يعني
مثل ايش مثل
القصور الغده الدرقيه هذا مرض وراثي مثل
التليف الكيسي ليصيب
الرئه والجهاز الهضمي هذا برضو مرض ورا
مثل الضمور العضلات برضو من امراض
المنتشره عندنا مرض وراثي
نامل انه في المستقبل يكون في يعني تركيز
اكبر على
الامراض الاخرى غير امراض الدم التي بلا
شكل البرنامج نجح بشكل كبير في الحد من
انتشارها
ايش اخطر الامراض اللي ما زالت موجوده
الامراض الوراثيه دكتور لانه في حالات
كثير من اعاقات نشوفها باقارب تتزوجوا وهم
في سن شاب يعني في سن صغيره ولديهم اثنين
او ثلاثه يعني من هؤلاء الاطفال المصابين
بس دعني اوضح نقطه مهمه
الامراض الوراثيه بشكل عام بشكل عام ما في
لا يوجد هناك علاج جذري
ممكن ياخذوا المريض ويتم الشفاء الكامل
وتعديل وتعديل الطفره الوراثيه
انما هناك علاج مساعد
مساند علاج تاهيلي علاج وظيفي اما
العلاجات التي
يعني تكون لها فائده اكبر هي المشموله
الان في البرنامج الفحص المواليد اللي هي
18 مرض استقلابي مع مرضين في الغده في
الغده الصماء اللي هم الغده الدرقيه
والغده البار كظري
في حالات ماساويه كتير الدكتور انا اريد
ان اسال عن هذه هذه تحديدا انت تعرف انه
الفحص الزواج ملزم ويمكن يعني يوفر لكثير
من الناس الامكانيه انه ينظر لمستقبل
الزواج ومستقبل اسرته واطفال لكن بالرغم
من ذلك التقيد بالنتيجه غير ملزمه للطرفين
بمعنى ممكن تكون النتيجه غير متوافقه
وممكن كذلك هذا التحليل او هذا الفحص وصحح
لي يعني انت المتخصص اكثر ممكن يتنبا بما
يمكن ان يحدث ومع ذلك يكون هناك يعني
اصرار من الطرفين على الزواج
الا يجب ان يتم الان اعاده النظر في هذا
الامر مراعاه لهذه يعني الحالات التي
نراها يعني مازلنا نراها بالرغم من كل هذه
البرامج
اتفق معك انه انه لا زالت هناك حالات
وفيها يصر الزوجان على اكمال اكمال عمليه
الزواج رغم تحذيراتنا لهم ونصحنا لهم انه
ممكن يكون في اولاد
مصابين بمرض الانيمه المجاليه او بحر
المتوسط اسالك علميا كم نسبه انه نتائج
هذا الفحص تكون صحيحه بمعنى انه
انتم ستتلقون ابناء يعني لديهم مشكله
وراثيه
هو اذا كان في علامات في التحليل المبدئي
اللي هو التحليل الدم
فهما الخطوه الثانيه انهم بيعملوا
يعملوا اللي هو
قياس لتركيز الهيموجلوبين والخاص
والبروتين الخاص بالانيمه المجاليه او
البحر المتوسط
نسبه
الدقه يعني كبيره تصل الى 90% نعم من ذلك
يصر الطرفان على الزواج بالرغم من كل نعم
احنا فقط مجرد ننصح ونرشد ونوضح للعائله
انه ممكن يكون في اولاد وممكن يكون في
اصابات
ومعاناه للاهل في التنويم المتكرر لما
نقول 90% تشوف انه يجب ان يعاد في قرار
مساله
التقيد بنتيجه من الطرفين من عدمها من
المناحي طبيه يا دكتوره
وحتى انسانيه كمان يعني
ما يعني سواء سواء الدراسات اللي احنا
درسنا فيها واول المراكز الطبيه لم يكن
هناك الزام من قبلنا كاطباء على الاهل
بانهم لا يجب ان يتزوجوا للزواج هناك
نصائح هناك ارشادات لكن كاطباء لا يمكننا
بشكل
بشكل صاري انه نخبر الاهل بعدم او او بعدم
اكمال الزواج يعني نحن مجرد ننصح ونرشد
طبعا هم يتحملوا مسؤوليه اذا كانوا حبوا
يكملوا في العمليه ام لا شكرا جزيلا لك
المشرف على البرنامج الوطني فحص الامراض
استشاري الورات الطبيه الدكتور ضياء اعرف
شكرا
في السعوديه اعلن صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه عن توقيع اتفاقيه معروف الامريكيه
لتاسيس شركه في الرياض تهدف الى انشاء
مزارع عموديه داخليه في المملكه شركه او
شراكه ستسهم في توفير محاصيل محليه عاريه
الجوده على مدار السنه من خلال استخدام
تقنيه الزراعه الذكيه الخاصه بشركه من
المتوقع ان يصل حجم الطاقه
الانتاجيه السنويه لاول مزرعه في المملكه
1100 من المحاصيل الزراعيه لتكون الاكبر
من نوعها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا
ايضا في جده غربيه سعوديه ملتقى الاحتفاء
باللغه العربيه لشعوب الاسلاميه في مقر
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي تنظيم الملتقى جاء
ضمن حزمه من البرامج اللغويه والمبادرات
المتصله بتعزيز حضور اللغه العربيه
بمشاركه شخصيات اعتباريه ممثله في منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي ومجمع الملك سلمان
العالمي للغه العربيه وفي غيرها من
المنظمه
من جانبه ذكر الامين العام لمجمع الملك
سلمان العالمي للغه العربيه الدكتور عبد
الله الوشمي ان السعوديه تستعد لاقامه
فعاليه كبرى تتعلق باللغه العربيه في مقر
منظمه التجاره العالميه وذلك ضمن جهود
كبرى ايضا لتقويه اللغه العربيه عالميا
ينعقد هذا الملتقى بالتعاوني الوثيق مع
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي وهي ثاني اكبر
المنظمات الدوليه وبرعايه كريمه من صاحب
السمو الامير بدر بن عبد الله بن فرحان ال
سعود وزير الثقافه السعودي رئيس مجلس
امناء المجمع وذلك ضمن جهود مجمع الملك
سلمان العالمي للغه العربيه في تعزيز حضور
اللغه العربيه في المنظمات الدوله الدوليه
حيث قام المجمع برنامجها الكبير في ديسمبر
الماضي في مقر منظمه الامم المتحده ويستعد
قريبا لاقامه فعاليه كبرى في مقر منظمه
التجاره العالميه وذلك ضمن جهودي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في تعزيزي وقياده شؤون
اللغه العربيه في العالم
رابعا مستمره فيها بعد قليل استمرار اعمال
التطوير في قلعه زعبل في شمال السعوديه
شاهدون تاريخي يمتد لاربعه قرون
اهلا بكم من جديد دشنت الهيئه العمل للنقل
في السعوديه اول حافله نقل عام
كهربائيه في المملكه في مدينه جده ستقدم
خدماتها للسكان ضمن مسارات النقل العام
الهيئه واشاره الى ان هذه الخطوه تستهدف
تحقيق مستهدفات الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه
للنقل والخدمات اللوجستيه وذلك بخفض
الانبعاثات الكربونيه بنسبه
25% بحلول العام
2030 الهيئه ايضا كشفت بان الحافله التي
جرى تشغيلها او تشغيلها تستطيع السير ل
300 كيلو متر في الشحنه الواحده وتعد من
الحافلاتات الكفاءه العاليه وتستهلك
الكهرباء باقل من عشره في المئه مقارنه
بالحافلات الكهربائيه الاخرى
رئيس الهيئه العامه للنقل رماح الرماح ان
خطوه التدشين اول حافله كهربائيه في جده
تاتي ضمن خطه لتجربتها ومن تم اعتمادها في
كافه مناطق السعوديه وذلك لتحقيق مستهدفات
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل والخدمات
اللوجستيه
اول تجربه لحافله كهربائيه لتجربتها في
جده في اجواء جده في على مدار الموسم
لاختبارها ثم
توزيعها ونشرها في مدن المملكه المختلفه
حرصا من تقليل الانبعاثات من سيارات النقل
العام او مركبات النقل العام لدينا مستهدف
ان ينخفض تخفيض الانبعاثات الى 25% من
الانبعاثات هذا وكشف رئيس شركه السعوديه
للنقل الجماعي خالد الحقيل ان الاجواء
سواء الحاره او البارده جدا تعد من ابرز
التحديات التي تواجه استخدام الحافلات
الكهربائيه مشيرا الى ان نتائج الاختبارات
في مرحلتها الحاليه تعد جيده
اليوم الاهميه تكمن في قضيه المملكه اليوم
تنتقل مع الركب العالمي في استخدام
الحافلات الكهربائيه الصديقه للبيئه
لتقليل الانبعاثات جزء منه
للحصول على حافلات اليوم صديقه للبيئه
وتتناسب مع اليوم التطور اللي يصير في
صناعه النقل اليوم الحافلات الكهربائيه لا
شكلنا من التحديات في قضيه اليوم الاجواء
الحاره او البارده جدا طبعا حنا اليوم في
اول خط في مدينه جده مدشنه لنضع
الاختبارات اللي لها الحمد نتائجه مبشره
من جده ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سعود
الخلف سعود مرحبا بك
سعود انت تتواجد الان بجانب احدى هذه
الحافلات الكهربائيه يعني سؤالك عن هذه
الحافله ما هي مواصفاتها هل جدا مؤهله
لتقديم الدعم اللوجستي يعني لهذا من توفر
بطاريات شواحن ايضا في الطرق التي تسلكها
هل الجده باجوائها ايضا يمكن ان تكون مكان
مناسب لهذه الحافلات معروفه اجواء جده
يعني وخاصه في الصيف
في الرياض ما شاء الله عايشين اجواء ولا
احلى مع مع الشتاء الله يعين بس عموما مثل
ما ذكرت انت في بدايه الخبر يوم امس كان
تدشين لهذه الحافلات اليوم اول رحله
ستنطلق لهذه الحافله واحنا بناخذ جوله
وبناخذ معلومات كثيره يا خالد طبعا هي
حافله كهربائيه وهذا المكان هو المكان
الذي يتم شحن فيه الحافله بمده معينه طبعا
في معلومات كثيره منها اللي انت سالت عنها
خالد وراح نتعرف عليها ولكن بعد ان ندخل
الى الحافله ونتعرف عليها منه الاستاذ
محمد بن سعيد القحطاني وهو مدير مشروع
النقل في جده
تفاصيل كثيره يعطيك العافيه استاذ محمد
ومباركة هذه الخطوه باذن الله البدايه هل
جده مؤهله لاستقبال هذه الحافلات
الكهربائيه من خلال المسارات وايضا
مشروع النقل هل هو مهيا للبطاريات اعداد
كافيه معلومات كثيره الناس تتساءل عنها
ومنها خالد زميلنا من الاستوديو اهلا
وسهلا حياك الله اخوي سعود شكرا على تاحه
الفرصه هذه لشرح مبسط بالنسبه
الحافله الكهربائيه طبعا بدايه كانت امس
بحضور معالي مدير هيئه رئيس هيئه النقل
العام ومعالي امين مدينه جده والحمد لله
اليوم بدايه
تشغيل الحافله الكهربائيه على احدى مسارات
مشروع النقل عام بجده طيب يعني خلينا
نتكلم عن المسارات كم عندنا مسار وهل خصص
مسار معين ومحدد لهذه الحافله طبعا عندنا
مشاريع بالنسبه للمسارات عندنا ثمانيه
مسارات لمشروع النقل العام في جده طبعا تم
اضافه عليها بالنسبه للمسارات اللي هي
مسار مطار الحرمين ومسار قطار قطار الدولي
عبد العزيز الدولي وقطار الحرمين اضافه
طبعا نحن خصصنا الحافله الكهربائيه لاحدى
مسارات مشروع النقل العام اللي هي مسار
سبعه اللي هو الخالديه البلد حلو طب احنا
كم عندنا حافله حافله ثنتين ثلاثه بالنسبه
الان كتجربه هي حامله واحده الان تجربه
لحافله الكهربائيه ليش تجربه يعني ما في
ثقه في المساله ولا ايش والله اول شيء
الحافلات تحتاج الى تقييم لازم تقييم اي
مشروع تبغى تبدا تنفذه خاصه حول
الكهربائيه والاجواء اللي موجوده في
السعوديه مختلفه عن الاجواء الصين مخت
الاجواء اوروبا فبالتالي تحتاج الى ثلاثه
الى سته شهور وبالتالي تقيم تجربتك
بالنسبه للحافله الكهربائيه جميل طب احنا
عندنا حافله واحده كم المده التي تحتاجها
لشحن البطاريه بشكل كامل وكم المده التي
تستغرقها ايضا الحافله في نفاذ البطاريه
طبعا هي تستغرق شحن البطاريه من 20% الى
90% و100% تقريبا ساعه ونص الى ساعتين
طبعا تستغرق الى تقطع مسافه 300 الى 350
كيلو متر بالنسبه لكامل البطاريه
حافله واحده
والتجربه سته اشهر
مباركة لكم هذه الخطوه ان شاء الله بعد
سته اشهر سنلتقيكم لمعرفه تقييمكم لهذه
التجربه شكرا جزيلا لك عن النقطه هذه انه
تدشين هذا مو تدشين
هو تقريبا تدشين لتجربه ستستمر لمده من
ثلاثه الى سته اشهر خلال فتره هذه سيتم
اقرار اما صحيح ان تستمر وتتوقف بناء على
التحديات وبناء على الاجواء وغيرها من
الامور
حسب حسب المعلومات يا خالد انه هذه
التجربه يعني سيشاهد ويقيموا ما هي
النواقص وما هي الايجابيات ان كان هنالك
نواقص سيتم اضافتها طبعا موجود معنا في
الحافله مدراء من الشركه
المنتجه
للناس الان
الحين قاعد نخلص اللايف ونطلع معاهم بس
الاجواء ان شاء الله حلوه رحله سعيده يا
حبيبي وشكرا جزيلا لك سعود الخلف من جده
اكبر مسابقه للصيد المستدهم في السعوديه
انطلقت قبل ايام في شمال السعوديه في
محميه الشمال للصيد المستدام هذه المسابقه
تهدف الى اكثار الطرائد بالاسر ثم اطلاقها
في بيئه طبيعيه جزاء يرافق احد الصقارين
في رحلتهم للبحث عن طائر الحبارة نتابع
محميه الشمال للصيد المستدام اول محميه من
نوعها في السعوديه تم تدشينها حديثا على
مساحه 2000 كيلو متر مربع وهي من ابرز
المبادرات التي عملت عليها مؤخرا هيئه
تطوير محميه الامام تركي بن عبد الله
الملكيه الشمال للصيد المستدام هي محميه
مخصصه لصيد الحباري ما نعرف انه صدور مرور
تاريخي وثقافي بالنسبه لنا لسكان الجزيره
العربيه وهذا هو استمرار لهذا الموروث
والتاريخ الثقافي والانساني على ارض
الجزيره العربيه ونطبح ان شاء الله ان
تكون هذه المحميه والمسابقه اللي تليها
جزء بسيط من هذا التفعيل اكبر مسابقه من
نوعها في السعوديه للصيد المستدام انطلقت
في محميه الشمال وبالطريقه التراثيه وهي
الصيد بالصقور والطرائد هي الحباري التي
تم اطلاقها في بيئتها لتكون قابله للصيد
بشكل يومي على مدى عشره ايام في عمليه
تنافسيه بين 600 صقار تم اختيارهم من اصل
ثمانيه الاف متقدم 600 متسابق يتم اختيارا
بطريق القرعه الالكترونيه ستسابقه بتوزعون
على عشره ايام كل اربع متسابقين في فريق
وبالتالي بيدخلون في عمليه منافسه عمليه
المنافسه ليست محصوره على الاسرع في الصيد
او الاقوى في الطير او غيره وانما هدفها
محصور هو على الاهداف اللي ظهرت منها
محميه الشمال للصيد المستدام المحافظه على
البيئه المحافظه على شروط البيئيه محافظه
ايضا كذلك على نظافه المحميه وايضا
الاسهام في نشر هذه الاهداف على نطاق
المحميه تسعى محميه الشمال للصيد المستدام
الى حمايه الحياه الفطريه وتنميه السياحه
البيئيه من خلال تطوير برنامج رياضي للصيد
المستدام معتمد على اكثار الطرائد بالاسر
وا في بيئه طبيعيه من محميه الشمال للصيد
المستدام جزاعا ماصي العربيه
[موسيقى]
منطقه الجوف في شمال السعوديه تضم حصولا
وقلاعا ثريا تعود الى مراحل زمنيه مختلفه
منها قلعه زعبل التي يعود بناءها الى
الفتره النبطيه الممتده من القرن الاول
قبل الميلاد في شمال مدينه سكاكا القلعه
التاريخيه يجري في محيطها حراك من التطوير
من خلال اعمال الترميم والانشاءات التي
تتكامل مع طابع العمراني والاثري للقلعه
وذلك لتعزيز وصول السياح والزوار كونها
تعد من المعالم التاريخيه والسياحيه
المهمه في المنطقه
من قلعه زعبل او زعبل في منطقه الجو في
شمال السعوديه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
عبد الواحد عبد الحميد حياك الله عبد
الواحد عبد الواحد اولا الاسمين صح ولا
واحد منهم الصح ربما والامر الثاني خلينا
نتعرف اكثر على هذه القلعه معك
اهلا بك خالد نعم طبعا باللهجه نقول زعبل
هي الاكثر يعني انتشارا بين سكان المحليين
نحن هنا في هذه القلعه اسفل القلعه تحديدا
حيث هناك العديد من البيوت التاريخيه
والاثريه نحاول ان نريكم القلعه في الاعلى
هي قلعه شاهقه جدا اسفلها يوجد العديد من
البيوت والمنازل التاريخيه التي يتم فيها
طبعا تم فيها ترميم سابقا في هذه البيوت
بالنسبه للقلعه هناك طبعا كما تعلم اكثر
من 3000 سنه تقريبا عمر هذه القلعه
فيما يتعلق بتفاصيل هذه القلعه اود ان
نتعرف اكثر من خلال لقائنا بالاستاذ نايف
اللحيد وهو مهتم بتاريخ قلعه بل اهلا
وسهلا بك استاذ نايف نريد ان نعرف اولا
تفاصيل هذه القلعه مما تتكون طبعا القلعه
هي مبنيه على يعني على تقريبا على طول 50
متر وهي تتكون من الصخر الرملي وبها شيء
من الطين
فيها في الاعلى على اربع ابراج تتولى
المراقبه وتكمن اهميه القلعه قلعه زعبل في
ذلك الوقت وفي تلك الحقبه تحديدا بانها
طال عمرك مسؤوله عن حمايه الحي وحمايه
مدينه سكاكا والاشراف على الطرق التجاريه
في ذلك الوقت وايضا الحمايه فكان صمودها
يعني صمود الحي وصمود المدينه وسقوطها في
ذلك الوقت يعني سقوط مدينه سكاكا فالقلعه
تكون اهميتها بكونها قلعه حربيه حصينه
مسؤوله عن حمايه المدينه والحج طيب
بالنسبه لي طبعا
المواد اللي تم صناعه من هذه القلعه نعرف
ان القلعه تم ترميمها تقريبا في اخر 200
سنه او قبل 300 سنه تقريبا الرممه القلعه
على وقت القرش حقيقه وكان الهدف من
الترميم هو اعاده دفاعاتها وتحصينها ايضا
الابراج تم كان طولها قصير ورفعت الى خمس
امتار تقريبا
لاعاده ترميمها من جديد وتحصينها بالنسبه
لهذا المكان اللي نحن متواجدين فيه الحين
قصر المسقوف وش قصته هذا طال عمرك المسقوف
كان يجتمعون فيه في وقت الازمات وتحديدا
المشاكل تمر في تلك الحقبه في المنطقه كان
يتناول فيه المواضيع السياسيه في ذلك
الوقت وطرق علاجها وحلها والتعاون فيما
بينهم طيب اخيرا استاذ نايف يعني نعرف ان
هذا المكان يعد يعني احد رموز منطقه الجوف
وطبعا
حتى الزوار والسياح ياتون باستمرار الى
هذه المناطق لزياره المساكن التاريخيه
والمنازل اسفل القلعه طبعا هي يعني تعتبر
صراحه متنفس للجميع كونها يعني مكان
تاريخي طلع يعني يعبر عن اصاله المنطقه
وعرقتها وتاريخها بقلعتها الشامخه وبيوتها
التي تمثل وتحاكي البيوت الموجوده في
الجزيره العربيه
والناس يستمتعون حقيقه بالطلوع الى اعلى
القلعه والاطلاع على مدينه سكاكا
يزورها الناس والزوار والسكان وحتى السياح
باستمرار
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من قناه في منطقه الجوف
في شمال السعوديه مراسل العربيه عبد
الواحد الحميد
في السعوديه اليوم الجمعه مهرجان ليفل او
مهرجان الملك عبد العزيز للابل بنسخته
السابعه بحضور امير منطقه الرياض الامير
فيصل بن بندر بن عبد العزيز وسلم امير
الرياض الفائزين في المهرجان جوائزهم التي
تصل قيمتها الى 300 مليون ريال سعودي
المهرجان ايضا الذي انطلق في الصياهد في
شمال الرياض بدايه من مطلع ديسمبر الماضي
شهد منافسات شديده بين مالكيليبل
المشاركين من المملكه ومن دول الخليج
العربي والعالم ايضا وسط حضور جماهيري
كبير لمحبي الابل
اعلنا برنامج الغذاء العالمي استئناف صرف
المساعدات الغذائيه للنازحين في مارب في
اليمن بعد الوصول الى اتفاق مع الجهات
المعنيه وكانت الوحده التنفيذيه للنازحين
نشرت صورا لاتلاف كميات من المواد
الغذائيه من قبل البرنامج منعت عن
النازحين خلال الاشهر الماضيه
اربعه اشهر من الجدل حول توزيع مساعدات
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي على النازحين في
مارب بصمات العين لكافه افراد الاسره
المستفيده من الغذاء واشتراطات اخرى تمسك
بها البرنامج ورفضتها بقوه سلطات مارب
للحفاظ على امن وخصوصيه النازحين بسببها
توقفت عمليه صرف الغذاء وبدا شبح المجاعه
يلوح في مخيمات النزوح طبعا هو كان يقول
ان لديه اجراءات جديده ادخل هذا ضمن خطه
البرنامج هذه الاجراءات
لم توافق عليها الجهه الامنيه والسلطه
المحليه داخل المحافظه نحن نعتبر من حق
السلطان المحليه الحفاظ على او من حق
الدوله الحفاظ على مواطنيها
فيها في هذه المرحله نحن يهمنا النازحين
وضع النازحين ويهمنا الا تحصل كارثه
انسانيه ومجاعه داخل المحافظه
فات مراكز التوزيع لمباشره صرف المساعدات
المخزنه لاكثر من اربعه اشهر في دورته
السابعه من العام 2022
واعلن عبر منصاته التوصل لاتفاق مع السلطه
المحليه على استئناف الصرف دون التطرق لحل
المشكله من عدمه وفي عمليه الصرف هذه
استمر البرنامج بخفض كميات واصناف الغذاء
المقدمه للنازحين
وعليها كان على زوجه جريح ولي زوجه استشهد
واللي ما بش معاها مقدرين انه يتمت حالتها
الان رجعوها كيس دقيق
وواحد بول يعني كيلو فول مدري كما هذا
والزيت هذا ما يستخدمه الناس
هذا لا يصلح للطباحه الجوع مع البرد يزيد
من معاناته ثلاثه ملايين من النازحين
والمجتمع المضيف في مارب فيما نشرت وحده
النازحين صورا لمواد غذائيه اتلفها برنامج
الغذاء العالمي اواخر يناير الماضي في
مديريه رغوان دون الرجوع للسلطات المعنيه
في المحافظه بعد اربعه اشهر من توقيفها
كما تؤكد الوحده التنفيذيه لاداره مخيمات
النازحين يعود برنامج الغذاء العالمي لصرف
السله الغذائيه للمواطنين ولكن بكميات اقل
محمود الحميدي لقناه العربيه مارب نختم
بالعناوين
يجدد التوتر استدعاء القائم باعمال الصين
في واشنطن تدعو للتهدئه والترامب يقول
اسقطه فورا
الامراض الوراثيه تعرق لوس المعدلاتها في
السعوديه مرتفعه وزواج الاقارب هو السبب
الاكبر
اول حافله كهربائيه لنقل الركاب في جده
شحنه واحده تكفي لقطع 300 كيلومتر
واستمرار اعمال التطوير في قلعه زعبل في
شمال السعوديه شاهد تاريخيا
لاربعه قرب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]